like one of the things that keeps kanye
west's relevant is that he's constantly
putting out music yeah constantly puts
out stuff that people love he constantly
put some stuff that smashes and some
guys lose their enthusiasm for
productivity yeah for being prolific
they how they lose that and then they
don't put out stuff anymore and then
they become like Rod Stewart yeah
Rod Stewart I'd like to see Rod Stewart
I'm a giant Rod Stewart fan like it when
Maggie Mae comes on the radio I get
excited I love that goddamn song I love
a lot of his music he was it but how
many tickets we sell right now yeah I'm
saying will he sell out the Staples
Center I don't think you know you know
you know when you I know you're still
working on Kanye coming on the show and
that's not even you know okay you know
what if he wants to do it but I don't
want to put any pressure on anybody
absolutely I don't necessarily know the
podcast for the best place for someone
for everybody it might not be the best
place to just talk about shit but did
you better just do music did you get to
talk to him at least on the phone yeah
yeah a nice guy let me tell you man he
is so opposite his persona like on the
outside like that you see in like in
gossip magazines and on TV I I used to
host his down to West foundation event
in Chicago and a lot of people don't
know the good he did and Chicago if they
had perfect attendance he would go there
every year throw a huge concert bringing
like common and all different type of
Chicago artists he would bus everybody
in from all over the city and throw a
free concert for all these kids that had
a perfect attendance and it was good to
interview him that way because he's sat
at that time at that time when his mom
was still alive he's such a down down
the earth humble guy and actually shy
and shy like he was really shy so wet
and this is at the time I would see
stories about him yelling at sway yeah
and like this is not the dude that I
interviewed he's volatile it was all
over the place
yeah that's part of why he's such an
explosive artist oh he's incredible
and Krauss guy those the people think
different and that stupid Apple ad think
different yeah there's people that
really do think different mm-hmm
differently that's one of the problems
with Apple ad
but the the there's people out there
that just have a different vibe there
and they're on a different frequency
they're different wavelength and they're
the ones who create great shit man he
has a gift I mean he is you know a lot
of people outside go oh he's out there
he's definitely out there he's yeah yeah
but he's a genius
yeah he is a genius he's doing something
in a different way
and that's that moves our culture along
that's what it's like that's what when
you're doing stand-up right like if
you're if you're nailing something if
you really lock down something and boom
you put out live on the Sunset Strip or
a delirious or somebody that you're
changing culture you're you're making
people people are gonna spread out in
these ripples yeah gonna go to their job
in the morning like we saw Michael yo
holy Shady doesn't joke about his cat
and whatever the fuck it is wherever the
joke is if people be crying laughing and
that there's ripples to that it's
positive ripples a change thing is